welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and Ahsoka has released new trailer
footage ahead of its release on August
23rd the first two episodes coming to
Disney plus with the reported combined
run time of 1 hour 36 minutes so we're
looking at two chunks of Star Wars
averaging 48 minutes or so each minus
credits around 40 minutes each so you
know just a full meal of live-action
Rebels really from a cameo of Harrison
Doula and Kane and Jerry's son Jason to
possible cameos by ahsoka's long-lost
Frenemy Baris offy I'm gonna break down
everything you missed from this trailer
footage and if you're one of the people
who didn't know what the hell I was just
saying with those names to catch you up
on rebels new rockstars will have four
videos coming up breaking down each of
the four seasons of rebels we're finally
getting around to this folks we're going
to talk about what happens in this
series the connections to Ahsoka and the
Mandalorian Star Wars Easter eggs you're
gonna love these videos so keep an eye
out for them also our Star Wars
aftershow Wikileaks will be coming back
on the break room Channel Wednesdays
starting August 23rd so please subscribe
to that channel and to this Channel and
before we get to this trailer sag after
it has informed us that entertainment
journalists like new rockstars are
allowed to cover TV shows like Ahsoka
but we stand with the writers and actors
and they're strike to make sure they are
not replaced with AI the way the
villains of Ahsoka seem to be pretty
reliant on Droids so this now or never
teaser opens with Ahsoka facing off with
an Inquisitor and what looks like an HK
87 series assassin Droid maybe a custom
version of it in this scrapyard location
that we've seen in another footage you
can see in the background an Imperial
Star Destroyer being broken apart in the
background on the left with the frame of
a spherical Shield generator at the top
of it I've speculated before that this
mystery Inquisitor rather than being
like the eighth brother who did fall but
might have survived that fall this could
actually be a female Inquisitor Baris
offy the Jedi who framed Ahsoka Tano for
the bombing of the Jedi Temple in season
5 of Clone Wars that was the false
persecution that led to Ahsoka party
ways of the Jedi Order Baris offy was
The Apprentice to Jedi Master luminar
and duly and in Breville season one The
Grand Inquisitor use luminara's corpse
to set a trap for Kanan and Ezra so
there may have been another Inquisitor
in the mix there Barris who could have
helped the inquisitors track down her
old master luminara and Barris could now
be one of the inquisitors this framing
between Ahsoka and this Inquisitor in
the scrap yard just looks so personal
and dramatic the way that Inquisitor
sheds the cape and it floats off in slow
motion just looks very evocative of
Samurai Cinema but listen to the audio
mix here there's so few Jedi left
she's coming so this is the late actor
Ray Stevenson as Bayland skull an
ex-jedi who carries an orange lightsaber
blade along with his Apprentice shinhati
in between his lines though is an
incredible vocalization forming the
score that these trailers have been
teasing for the series which is composed
by Kevin kiner who scored the amazing
final Arc of Clone Wars when ahsoka's
liberation of mandalor led to the
capture of maul in the events of order
66. balance Hollow projection is the
clearest I've ever seen in a Technicolor
at least until the very very clear
massive projection of snoke in the force
awakens that we initially thought was
real but that gold colored Hull behind
Halen makes this location look like the
bridge of the ship that we've seen Grand
Admiral thrawn and Morgan ellsmith on in
other shots so thrawn may have better
maintained his Hardware in his Fleet
more than other captains and ships that
we've seen in Star Wars in the past
which makes sense because thrawn is you
know he's just that kind of guy we hear
the voice of Ahsoka which is actually
part of a later scene that we see with
Sabine Wren as Ahsoka here says our
enemies are multiplying she is alluding
to what Captain Carson tiva has been
warning about throughout the Mandalorian
growing forces in the outer rim of what
will become the first order but also I
think she's referring to the fleet of
thrawn and that doesn't necessarily mean
that thrawn's Fleet will become the
first order I personally think it's
going to be separate forces Ahsoka and
someone else run through this red leafed
wooded area I think that's The
Inquisitor that she'll be fighting in
this location this is what borders the
dark colored ruins that we've seen in
other shots where the star map gets
projected once again there is a shot of
organelle Smith and shin and Balin in
that location Morgan's hand hovering
over a projection of the Galaxy over a
green colored flame as that star map is
projected over these ruins we know this
will be important because this imagery
also forms the background of the series
logo there's been a lot of speculation
these lines reflect the imagery of the
world Between Worlds that we saw in
Rebels but I'm thinking more and more
it's just a star map pointed to some
other important location like maybe the
realm of mortis now you don't have to be
Force sensitive to know that if you're
spending all day in the kitchen You're
Gonna Want an apron to keep your clothes
clean and if you're a Star Wars fan that
means you're gonna want one from Hedley
and Bennett's Star Wars collection
Headley and Bennett's Star Wars
collector's pizza box comes with four
essential aprons Boba Fett Darth Vader
Luke Skywalker and R2D2 box features art
inspired by classic Star Wars comics
from the 1970s a limited edition sticker
and a blue milk recipe card here is an
apron that I got from these guys oh man
oh man look I can fit my phone right in
there hell yeah bro the details on these
aprons are awesome the Boba Fett apron
has his sigil in a mythosar skull Luke
Skywalker's apron feels like his X-Wing
flight suit the R2D2 apron has a status
indicator and the Darth Vader apron
makes me feel like an imperial short
order cook it's great and to celebrate
the 40th anniversary of Return of the
Jedi Headley and Bennett also designed a
special edition Galactic Fleet apron and
this hyperspace towel set with the
lucasfilm team the Super Fan bundle
includes the entire Star Wars Headley
and Bennett collection so click the link
in the description or go to Headley and
bennett.com and use code new rockstars15
to get 15 off your first order but
listen to this part a galaxy is not safe
yeah I love how they mixed in the sound
of a star destroyer distressed siren
there's this new shot of Sabine on our
Speeder bike on the freeway on low fall
but at e-wing we saw in the last trailer
now flying away from her giving us a
better look of the e-wing body and I
just like how chunky this thing is like
it's got some real weight and some heft
to it another new shot of Harrison Doula
saying once a rebel always a rebel as
she looks over at some co-pilot over on
her side and in the hyperspace jump shot
you can see this other figure is short I
think this is her son also the son of
the late Kanan Jairus Jason cindula
while this kid doesn't seem to have
green hair in this shot there is a Lego
set of The Ghost and we do see the Lego
figure of Jason and it looks like the
series will change his hair color we
also see the ghost following ahsoka's T6
shuttle through some clouds this could
be the location that has all the giant
Pergo hyperspace whales in it Balin
orders his followers hunt them down
while standing in those dark ruins The
Inquisitor lights their double-sided
blade in this nearby Force followed by
Shin igniting her orange blade this is
in the hangar of that new Republic
Cruiser that we saw open the July
trailer but there is some trailer
editing deception here if you look
closely get ready ready ready yeah to
see that little war criminal Chopper
saying as he pumps his arm but while
Hera Chopper and Ahsoka all seem to be
synced on a mission here if you look
closely it's a bean in this shot she's
not actually saying red D that's not
what her mouth says they just dubbed her
audio over a different scene a scene
where she's using Ezra bridger's
lightsaber to duel shin and again whilst
the bean seems to have worked as an
apprentice to Ahsoka that being implied
by her calling Ahsoka master in the last
trailer I do not think Sabine is
actually Force sensitive she is just
good at using a lightsaber though based
off her training with Kanan Jairus when
he taught her how to use a dark saber
she's a Mandalorian who knows how to
wield a dark saber but I don't think
she's Force sensitive Ahsoka uses her
white blades to fight these HK 87
assassin droids the same kind used by
Morgan L Smith in the Mandalorian and
these brightly lit ruins in a location I
determined in the last Ahsoka video to
be a volcano based off of the black sand
scattered all over it and a lava
explosion from this location and this
shot of her Leap though we get the best
new yet of the statues in this location
both the one that's right behind her in
this angle and another one on the left
in the distance these figures are
cloaked and they're Barefoot but the one
on the left while its head has been
broken off you can see it is holding an
orb an orb with a little dimple that
looks like the Death Star but you know
that part's coincidental every sphere
with a nipple in it kind of looks like
the Death Star but this actually looks
like the same hooded female figure on
the inside of these ruins that we've
seen in the past and we get the shot of
ahsoka's red paint the T6 shuttle flying
past a larger looks like a mon calamari
Cruiser reminding me of the shot of the
falcon flying past the moncala cruiser
in the Battle of Endor in Return of the
Jedi and then the last new shot Sabine
in the Gunner seat blowing up another
ship letting out a woo in the style of
Han Solo or Finn look this looks like a
really fun show I think between the lore
that Dave filoni is going to continue
building from Rebels and complex
villains like thrawn and Balin cameos it
sounds like from Hayden Christensen as
Anakin and Clone Wars era flashbacks and
just really nuanced design choices like
the music and the star map aesthetic of
everything Ahsoka could just end up
being a very very interesting Series so
I'm really excited to break it down for
you please subscribe to all three
channels in the new rockstars Network
you can follow me on social platforms at
eavos follow me rockstars thanks for
watching everybody see you next time bye
[Music]